if you're ready for some comedy it's
been a little heavy so far in the show
so let's let's do some comedy i think a
little bit of a comedic relief um wanda
sykes who's a famous comedian
she was on with stephen colbert another
famous comedian they're doing it's a
late night show
this is a time to just you watch late
night shows you kick back you relax you
have a good laugh is all and so here is
a little bit some more great comedy
from uh from stephen colbert on the late
show listen
how are you doing how you doing i'm a
black gay woman and i have a daughter so
i'm not doing so well right now
i'm a little salty
you're a little salty i'm a little salty
right now okay yeah yeah we'll sprinkle
a little salt yeah
let's put some flavor on it sucks man it
it it really does i mean you know it's
like the
the country it's no longer a democracy
right i mean we're it's no longer
majority rule no certainly not the
senate certainly yeah
it's not it's not it's no longer
majority rule and and i mean it's like
the these judges that just
they basically lied when they were you
know being during their confirmation
hearings right yeah
especially kavanaugh
yeah
so how you how can you be a supreme
court justice and you just you're just
lying you know what they had their
fingers crossed or something or what i
mean
it's yeah it's just it's just a bunch of
horse it really is
[Applause]
well to me it's like the problem is that
middle stuff
is it's those states in the middle that
that that red stuff
why they get to tell us what to do when
the majority of us live
out you know new york california and
we're paying for all this crap really i
mean right
great comedy is always from the late
show stephen colbert i mean in a certain
way it is great comedy and uh also it
gives us it gives us some more insight
into the mindset of the elitist liberal
because everything you just heard there
was was
confused garbled
um here is what we find this this
mix this very potent mixture of
rampant stupidity
um mixed with this snobby
dismissal you know this self-important
dismissal of the majority of the country
so on one hand she's like oh the red
stuff the re she's talking about human
beings by the way
those are human beings if you're if
you're if you disagree with her if
you're a conservative then you're just
red stuff gets just get rid of it sweep
it away just yeah whatever
just maybe just send in send in the the
troops just you know just get rid of
them
ship them off somewhere
uh that's how she views
most of the country
red stuff
and while she's saying that she's also
revealing that she
she does not understand at all how our
system of government actually works
so you say it sounds it's like what is
it what happened to majority rule
this is a supreme court decision wanda
it's majority rule on the court
okay but that's not how court the
supreme court they don't take a poll
of
americans and then decide based on that
that's just not how the supreme court
works
and by the way just see a no if they if
things were decided that way
um we would not have what you want which
is abortion from you know legal abortion
from
uh moment of conception all the way till
birth
because it's only a very small sliver of
the most deranged and bloodthirsty and
morally debased americans like like
wanda sykes and others
who
favor that
so you wouldn't actually want majority
rule
in the first place
uh but either way that's not how the
supreme court makes decisions
but as we know
um when institutions like we talked
about a couple days ago
institutions are broken
they don't work anymore
they need to be
reformed or
destroyed incinerated and rebuilt
when they stop doing what the left wants
the moment they fall out of line out of
step
with what the left demands they're
broken that means they're broken now and
they have to be
we have to get rid of them throw them in
the wood chipper well if you enjoyed
that video be sure to hit the subscribe
button and ring the bell to get more
content like it if you're craving more
content go watch or listen to my full
show at dailywire.com spotify or
wherever you get your podcast